>> Greg: ARE YOU TELLING A FIB
ABOUT WHAT YOU WATCH IN YOUR
CRIB?
A BRITISH POLL, MY FAVORITE
KIND, JOE, FOUND THAT 52% OF
PEOPLE LIE ABOUT WATCHING
POPULAR TV SHOWS IN ORDER TO
IMPRESS OTHERS AND APPEAR
COOLER.
THE MOST GLAD ABOUT SHOWS WERE
STRANGER THINGS, GAME OF
THRONES, BREAKING BAD, THE
CROWN, AND SCHITT'S CREEK.
SOME PEOPLE LIED ABOUT SEEING MY
SHOW.
THE PUNISHMENT WILL BE TO WATCH
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
MORE PEOPLE SAW THAT HERE THAN
THERE.
THANK YOU, I WILL TAKE IT.
I WILL TAKE THAT.
DESPERATE PLEA FOR APPLAUSE.
I DON'T HAVE THIS PROBLEM OF
LYING PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT I WATCH.
I WATCH ENDLESS EPISODES OF THE
GOLDEN GIRLS COMPLETELY NUDE.
I GET OUT OF THE SHOWER AND SIT
ON THE REMOTE.
IT SOUNDED BETTER WHEN I WROTE
IT.
BUT IT JUST GOES TO SHOW, MOST
PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE TO BE
ACCEPTED AND NOT JUST CAT.
YOU CAN WATCH HER ON THE REAL
HOUSE WIVESES WITH FAKE HAIR.
>> OH, I AM A REAL HOUSEWIFE.
>> WITH FAKE HAIR.
>> YEAH.
>> MAYBE SOME PEOPLE ARE SICK OF
OTHERS BADGERING THEM TO WATCH
CERTAIN SHOWS, WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE.
>> HEY, DID YOU GET THAT GAME OF
THRONES MEME I SENT YOU?
>> DELETED IT.
I TOLD YOU, I NEVER WATCHED GAME
OF THRONES.
>> WHAT?
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN IT?
IT'S LIKE SAYING YOU NEVER SAW
DOWNTOWN ABBEY OR STRANGER
THINGS OR WEST GIRLS OR VERONICA
MARS.
>> LIKE I TOLD YOU A MILLION
TIMES, I DIDN'T WATCH ANY OF
THAT GARBAGE EITHER.
I'M SELECTIVE AND I ONLY WATCH
TV THAT I CONSIDER TO BE A WORK
OF ART, THE CREME DE LA CREME.
NOW, IF YOU'LL EXCUSE ME.
>> HE HAS THAT EFFECT.
WHY -- WHY -- OKAY.
THERE'S TWO INSTINCTS HERE.
THERE'S THE PERSON THAT HAS TO
HAVE YOU WATCH THESE SERIES.
YOU MEAN, YOU HAVEN'T WATCHED
THE QUEEN'S GAMUT -- OR THE
KING'S GAMUT.
I WATCH IT, IT'S TERRIBLE.
WHAT DOES IT MATTER.
THEN THE OTHER THING IS WHY DO
WE LIE?
>> BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE THE
PERSON WHO'S ASKING US.
WE SAY I SAW IT, IT SUCKS.
THEN WE MOVE ON.
SO, FOR YOU AND ME, IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
WE'RE SELECT MOVIE CRITICS OF
THE HIGHEST ORDER.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
>> WE DISCUSS JUST EVERYTHING.
>> WAY OVER YOUR HEAD.
I WON'T EVEN BOAR YOU WITH THE
INTELLECT.
AND IT DOESN'T BOTHER US THAT
OTHER PEOPLE IN OUR HOUSE HOLD
GO WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU
WATCHING AND LEAVE THE ROOM.
NO ONE ASKS US TO WATCH
SOMETHING.
WE WILL WATCH IT AND JUDGE YOU
AS A PERSON HOW YOU RECOMMENDED
IT.
IT WAS A POOR LITTLE SOUND GUY,
WE'LL CALL HIM DEON, REMEMBER.
HE TRIED TO JOIN THE MOVIE CREW.
CHECK OUT THE MODELS.
I DIDN'T SEE IT.
GUTFELD SENT ME AN E-MAIL AND HE
SAID, THIS WAS HORRIBLE.
I WENT WITH IT.
TOGETHER, WE DESTROY HIM AS A
PERSON.
HOW DARE YOU?
THAT MOVIE WAS TERRIBLE.
>> IT WAS THE WORST MOVIE I HAVE
EVER SEEN.
>> HE ASKED ME, WHICH PART DID
YOU WATCH?
ALL OF IT?
I WAS OFFENDED, RIGHT, GREG?
GREG TOLD US THE REST.
THAT'S HOW WE ROLL.
>> EXACTLY.
EXACTLY.
MACKEY, DO YOU LIE ABOUT THIS
SORT OF THING?
>> GREG GRUT FELT, I DON'T HAVE
TO LIE TO IMPRESS PEOPLE, OKAY?
IN FACT, RECENTLY, A BEAUTIFUL
LADY APPROACHED ME AND SAID,
HAVE YOU EVER WATCHED GAME OF
THRONES.
AND I SAID, NO, I DON'T CARE
ABOUT IT.
THAT WAS WHEN I SEDUCED HER.
THAT'S HOW I IMPRESS PEOPLE.
I LIE ABOUT SEDUCING WOMEN.
>> IT WORKS.
ON THE EDGE OF MY FEET.
>> THAT ONE TOOK ME FOR A RIDE.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW WHERE I WAS
GOING.
>> NO GIRL?
>> NO.
NOTHING HAPPENED AND I'M A
TERRIBLE LIAR.
THAT'S WHY WHEN PEOPLE ARE LIKE,
DID YOU WATCH THAT SHOW?
OH, THE SAVED BY THE BELL WHERE
KELLY WAS PREGNANT?
>> WAIT, KELLY WAS PREGNANT?
>> NO.
>> YOU GOT ME AGAIN.
>> I GET OVERWHELMED, CAT, WHEN
I TURN ON -- WHEN I GO TO
NETFLIX, THERE'S TOO MANY
OPTIONS.
BY THE TIME I'VE GONE THROUGH
20, I NO LONGER WANT TO WATCH.
45 MINUTES I SPEND CLICKING ON
CRAP.
I REALIZE, WE HAVE MORE VARIETY
BUT WE HAVE NO QUALITY.
RIGHT?
NO QUALITY.
>> PROBABLY.
YEAH, I LOVE THE STUFF THAT
SUCKS.
>> YOU DO?
>> WHAT ARE YOU WATCHING?
>> NO, THAT'S GOOD.
BUT THERE'S NO PREGNANT TEENS IN
THAT, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> WE GOT THEM ALL.
RIGHT HERE.
>> COOL.
I'LL MOVE THERE.
>> DAY CARES IN HIGH SCHOOL,
IT'S COOL.
>> AWESOME.
TEEN MOM -- TEEN MOM 2.
YOU KNOW, TEEN MOM, YOUNG AND
PREGNANT.
>> WE SEE THE TEEN MOMS COME
BACK IN THEIR 20s AND GIVE
ADVICE.
>> SOME OF THE TEEN MOMS -- A
LONG TIME.
THEY'RE ALL RICH.
THEY'VE BEEN TEEN MOMS FOR SO
LONG.
IT'S BORING.
I STILL WATCH IT.
I DON'T LIE TO IMPRESS. I DO LIE
SOMETIMES.
I DO SAY YEAH, BABE, I ALREADY
SAW IT SO WHAT FOLLOWS IS NOT,
LET'S WATCH THIS TOGETHER SINCE
YOU HAVE NOT SEEN IT.
YEAH, BABE, SAW IT.
YOU CAN TURN ON THE TEEN MOMS
AGAIN LIKE YOU REALLY WANTED.
>> IT'S REALLY WEIRD TO WATCH A
MOVIE YOU'VE SEEN WITH SOMEONE
WHO HASN'T WATCHED IT AND YOU
START TO GET IRRITATED AND NOT
PAYING ATTENTION.
>> THIS IS GOOD.
THIS IS GOOD.
>> WE WANT ALONE.
>> YOU HAVE TO WATCH MOVIES
ALONE.
>> NOT TO BE RUDE, BUT ISN'T
TEEN MOMS 3 GRANDMAS?
>> NO.
>> THEY'RE TURNING 30 NOW.
>> THE TEEN MOMS ARE TURNING 30.
>> 30 SOMETHING GRANDMAS.
>> YEAH, THERE'S BABY DADDY
DRAMA AND SO ON.
BUT IT'S NOT -- SOME OF THE
NETFLIX 3.
>> THERE'S A DUDE OUT THERE WITH
MULTIPLE TEEN MOM BABY MAMAS.
>> IT'S NOT ME.
>> I WANT TO GET YOUR OPINION ON
THIS STORY.
DO YOU LIE ABOUT WHAT YOU WATCH?
>> I DO NOT DEPENDS ON THE
QUESTION.
IN THIS CONTEXT, I DO NOT LIE
ABOUT WHAT I WANT.
WHAT I WILL DO, I WATCH THIS
WORK-AROUND, I WATCHEVER EPISODE
OF EVERY SHOW.
YOU MET ALL OF THE CAST AND YOU
PRETTY MUCH KNOW THE PLOT.
BREAKING BAD, I DID IT.
YELLOWSTONE, I DID IT.
DON'T MENTION YELLOWSTONE, THIS
WEEK WAS A BAD WEEK.
>> I HEAR IT'S A TERRIBLE SHOW.
>> I HEARD A LOT OF MURDERING
AND --
>> I LOVE BREAKING BAD.
>> KEVIN COSTNER IS A SAINT.
>> I LIKE KEVIN COSTNER.
>> HAVEN'T TALKED TO HIM IN A
WHILE.
GOT TO GET BACK TO HIM.
HI HAS MY SWEATSHIRT.
>> THE MAILMAN, RIGHT?
>> WATER WORLD, MAILMAN, RIGHT?
>> ON SPECK, BY THE WAY.
>> THE ONLY THING I WOULD STREAM
ARE SHOWS ABOUT STREAMS.
>> STREAMING SHOWS, THERE'S A
FOX NATION NETWORK.
EVERYBODY SHOULD CHECK IT OUT.
>> WHAT'S IT CALLED?
>> FOX NATION?
>> DO YOU HAVE A SHOW ON THERE?
>> YEAH, A COUPLE, YEAH.
YOU CAN WATCH ME AND MY
CELEBRITY FRIENDS KILL ANIMALS
ON FOX NATION OUTDOORS.
>> THE BEST STREAMING -- I'M
GOING TO BE SINCERE.
THE BEST SHOW TO STREAM IS LIKE
OLD EPISODES.
ONLY OLD EPISODES OF COLOMBO.
IF YOU GET TO A COLOMBO GROOVE,
THERE'S NO WAY OUT.
THE PLOT, EVERYTHING IS THE
SAME.
YOU GET TO SEE PEOPLE LIKE
WILLIAM SHATNER OR JACK CASSIDY.
>> I WROTE COLOMBO AND --
>> IT'S GOT TO BE MAT LOCK THEN.
>> I'M NOT A MAT LOCK.
>> MURDER SHE WROTE?
>> STOP IT.
>> MURDER SHE WROTE.
>> ANGELA LANSBURY.
>> YOU'RE A PERVERT.
>> YOU ARE CALLING SOMEONE A
PERVERT.
YOU HAVE A CAPITAL P TATTOOED ON